we are indeed with the a-time national
champion Irina Crush Irina first of all
congratulations it felt like you were
getting so close each and every game
through that Victory but it was just so
elusive
oh yeah I mean it was pretty depressing
um to go three games without a decisive
result and
um you know this is my first time
earning the right to see you guys in the
studio pretty happy about that and uh
you know yeah of course
um the way the tournament started I
don't think I've ever had a U.S
championship start like that without you
know three games without a win
um it was quite disappointing I mean I
was definitely so close I had good
positions in all the games and I mean
against Sabina it was like almost there
and then such a promising position
against Megan Lee after the exchange
sack and even that kind of escaped me
when she found the draw in the king and
pawn end game even without even the
first round you had a better position
maybe a bit worse after that and it
finally ended in a draw is it something
about the length of the event that makes
Players let's say play a bit more
conservative well the thing is I'm not
playing very conservatively I'm just
actually like even yesterday
um I had like a pretty safe option to
trade Queens out of the opening and I
was like well that's perfectly fine from
a chess point of view but
um I chose to keep the Queens on the
board keep my king in the center and
obviously a lot more risky so I wouldn't
say that I'm actually playing
particularly conservatively but you know
I just didn't um capitalize on those
advantages I had
um and yeah I mean it feels really good
to get that win to play like a pretty
clean game Let's uh go through the game
actually and take us through the opening
phase yeah so well she always plays the
nimso so this opening is not a huge
surprise although it might be one of our
first names against each other like I
don't think I've ever played into the
nimso against her
um sorry to interrupt I do think we have
a result Wesley saw has won his game
against Sam Shanklin
let's continue yeah
so Wesley is that another person who's
getting a win for the first time
defending Champion yeah and
um okay so she played this B6 line I
think you know this first part it was
kind of obvious it was my preparation
right because I played quite quickly
absolutely
um
A3 Bishop E7 yeah
Knight to F4 and we don't want to go too
much into the details of the opening
phase Queen to G yeah Queen to D7 I mean
yeah that's kind of the idea that black
will eventually have to do so the
position looks very aggressive right
when white starts pushing these pawns
but in fact it's it's uh you know the
queen trade is is almost inevitable it's
only a question of like in which you
know should she do like another move
here and do it right away so she played
very naturally I'll tell you like what
was the key moment we'll keep going sure
yeah so I have this plan of trading the
Bishops here I was wondering I was like
should I go should I move my knight away
or should I go just for this uh night
seating along with a trade of knights
one pair of nights at least and so when
I played Bishop A3 and then she took and
I thought you know okay I got what I
wanted and I was like wow this is not so
simple because she's actually pretty
close to playing the move C5 right I
mean she has to go like Rook md8 which
is what she did right
and so this was pretty much the most
challenging
um moments of the game I think for me
right interesting because I was I was
like I was gonna say because I have A5 I
have B4 and I have King E2 like all
these moves are possible
um and ultimately I chose King E2
thinking that you know she has so many
plans in this position right one of her
plans is A5 the other plan is Knight f8
96 and the other plan is king of fake
King E7 to D6 so I kind of just wanted
to give her a chance to choose a plan
and I thought my king on E2 would be you
know like for now let's wait although
yeah I mean it's true that if she plays
A5 actually I lose these ideas of
playing A5 or B4 right so she maybe she
should have done that
um but once she didn't so she went for
the night of Fate plan and somehow like
B4 turned out to be quite good
um like that was I was happy with this
position with the queen side majority
um yeah I see the computer's Edge is not
so big but certainly you know my king is
better my Pawn structure is better and
she has to be extremely yeah she has to
be very precise after 96 Knight D3 okay
well here was the key moment yeah she
had to play F6 right did you see this
movie yeah yeah she can't let my knight
into C6 because actually when I was
playing Knight D3 I was like calculating
all these lines where she plays D4 is C4
because it's quite critical but I
realize it just doesn't work like the
pawns don't really go anywhere and the
Knight on C6 is so strong and the final
moment I'll just show you and this is
what happened in the game yeah this was
the final moment I was like deciding
where to put my king should I go to F3
so that there's not any Knight C5 or
should I go to D2 allowing Knight C5 and
then playing F3 and basically I mean
it's kind of like a beautiful position
here because the king is so good on D2
and when she let's say she plays
something like rookie AIDS right right
so I go uh Rook C1 and all of my pieces
are just on perfect squares like the
pawns are about to go and okay Knight B3
doesn't work because of this kind of
important forcing line very nice yeah
king of Fate uh Knight C8 B2 rugby one
Rook C8 and rugby two like everything is
in the perfect position for A5 B6 so
that was kind of the last uh critical
line of the game she played Rook to D7
yeah and then you just pick up the Pawns
and this was smooth sailing for you
Irina Irina congratulations a big
victory for you uh how are you feeling
about the tournament oh we're looking at
your chances much better you know I
really just needed I needed I needed to
win a game just to get that taste of
Victory and just to get that confidence
and I also feel like in general I'm
playing you know better game after game
so the first game was a bit shaky
definitely against tatv
um but you know I feel like as long as
you keep playing well like eventually
you should get the points so this was an
important game for me guys
wonderful congratulations Arena
definitely the sun shines a little bit
brighter after Victory ice cream tastes
uh much better as well uh the results
and they're coming in